depuis sa création il y a déjà été
consultée plus de 3 millions de fois ce
n'est pas le dernier clip de maître Gims
mais le simulateur de salaire proposé
par l'Observatoire des inégalités basées
à Tours comme on fonctionne cet outil et
comment expliquer son succès notre
invité nous réponds bonsoir vous êtes
directrice des études à l'Observatoire
des inégalités alors ça fait un certain
temps que cette simulateur est en place
pourquoi la voie l'avoir lancée c'est
plutôt même un comparateur de chaleur
c'est ça en fait si vous êtes de votre
votre écran en ce moment et vous avez un
smartphone dans les mains vous pouvez
faire le test demander à votre moteur de
recherche inégalité comparateur vous
allez arriver devant cette petite
fenêtre bleue qui vous invite à entrer
votre salaire net pour un temps complet
donc avant le prélèvement des impôts
vous allez pouvoir vous situer dans une
courbe qui représente l'ensemble des
personnes du secteur privé et savoir où
vous situer par exemple cette année les
chiffres sont particulièrement ronds et
donc en approxy enfin avec une toute
petite approximation je peux dire que si
vous rentrez 2000 euros vous êtes
exactement au milieu de la distribution
des salaires c'est à dire qu'il y a
autant de salariés qui gagnent plus que
vous que de salariés qui gagnent moins
salaire médian c'est bien ça d'accord si
vous rentrez 3000 alors il y a 80% des
personnes et si vous
rentrent 4000 alors vous êtes au début
des 10% les mieux payés donc ça permet
de se situer
de satisfaire une certaine curiosité de
se comparer aussi et comment expliquer
le succès de cet outil on l'a dit 3
millions d'utilisateurs ça simplicité
puis justement parce qu'on adore se
comparer aux voisins la simplicité c'est
sûr le fait aussi sans doute que ces
questions d'argent elles sont pas si
fréquemment évoquées on entend
fréquemment parler des écarts de salaire
entre les femmes et les hommes mais
l'ensemble de l'échelle des salaires il
faut reconnaître que c'est difficile de
savoir où on situe d'ailleurs il y a un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
surprises de voir que la France est
composée d'un très grand nombre de
personnes qui gagnent moins qu'elle donc
ça permet aussi de ramener un peu de
réalité sociale à des cadres parisiens
par exemple ou à des journalistes ça a
contribué je pense au buzz de cet outil
et puis
le dernier élément à notre intention
c'était tout simplement de donner de
l'information sur l'échelle des salaires
en France et des éléments simple pour
comprendre
vous vous basez sur des chiffres très
sérieux ceux de l'Insee c'est un
contestable alors au-delà de son côté
ludique ce que nous apprend ce
comparateur de salaire notamment pour
les salariés du privé et du public
salarié du public ne sont pas dedans je
peux vous en dire un mot dans un instant
si on en a pas le temps en tout cas
un écart
en tout cas un ratio un rapport de 1 à 3
à peu près entre ceux qui sont début des
10% les mieux payés et puis ceux qui
sont à la fin des 10% les moins bien
payés
ça nous dit pas en revanche jusqu'où
grimper ça l'air parce que là on
s'arrête à 9000 euros à peu près 8 fois
le SMIC c'est ce qui permet d'être dans
le 1% de mieux payer mais on sait on a
vu récemment annoncer la rémunération de
Carlos savares le PDG de stelantis
l'ancien groupe PSA que les
rémunérations elles peuvent monter bien
plus haut et ça nous dit pas non plus on
s'y intéresse moins souvent mais les
salaires qui sont tout en bas de
l'échelle notre courbe elle s'arrête sur
les 5% les plus faibles on n'a pas le
détail de la part de l'INSEE et je le
regrette il y a sans doute 5% des gens
qui gagnent moins que le SMIC en France
5% des gens qui gagnent c'est une
approximation mais en tout cas ça peut
avoir des temps partiels etc
mais on dirait rarement qu'il y a un
certain nombre de métiers ou de
situations dans lesquelles il est légal
de déroger au SMIC notamment pour les
jeunes en formation en alternance par
exemple mais aussi pour les assistantes
maternelles qui composent un nombre très
important de femmes au travail ou les
personnes handicapées en établissement
protégés ou les détenus par exemple donc
un certain nombre de situations qui
permettent de déroger aussi
effectivement est-ce que ça dit si on
est pauvre si on est riche aussi cet
outil on pourrait dire oui ça donne un
élément sur les salaires c'est majeur
dans les revenus en France en réalité on
regarde nous aussi les inégalités de
revenus plus précisément de niveau de
vie c'est-à-dire ce dont on dispose à la
fin du mois avec son salaire mais aussi
les autres sources de revenus qu'on peut
avoir les retraites si on a la retraite
mais aussi les revenus du capital qui
sont plus inégalitaires que les salaires
puisque on a un patrimoine c'est plus
rare d'avoir un gros patrimoine et d'en
tirer de l'argent et puis on retire
aussi les impôts pour savoir exactement
combien on a d'argent à la fin du mois
et on tient compte du nombre d'enfants à
charge tout ça fait que les écarts je
vous disais en termes de salaire c'est à
peu près 3 2,9
entre les 10% des mieux payés et les 10%
les moins bien payés pour les revenus on
monte à 3 et demi les inégalités sont
plus grandes quand on regarde l'ensemble
des revenus et ces inégalités se
creusent au fur et à mesure des années
ce qu'on peut le voir ça grâce à cet
outil on peut pas le voir grâce à
l'outil ça vous donne une photo un
instant donné là c'est des données de
2021 en revanche dans le rapport que
nous allons publier d'ici quelques mois
et pour lequel on appelle la financement
participatif donc c'est un petit signe
spectateurs s'ils ont envie d'y
participer on va donner des éléments
d'évolution sur les inégalités de
salaire qu'on est encore en train de
d'analyser elles ont été bouleversées
par la crise covid mais ce qu'on voit
depuis quelques années déjà c'est une
augmentation des salaires les plus
élevés merci beaucoup Anne Bruner de
l'Observatoire des inégalités devenus ce
soir sur notre plateau